so he did this town hall last night with
anderson cooper he is facing down a
crisis in terms of inflation a supply
chain crisis he is facing down a border
crisis he gave up afghanistan completely
destroying whatever possibility of the
future there was for 19 million afghan
women as well as thousands of siv
holders who are still sitting imprisoned
in afghanistan
he's got crises up to wazoo the
president of the united states and so
they sent him out there to stop the
bleeding
the problem is that if you're going to
send someone out there to stop the
bleeding you don't want them
congenitally falling on their own knife
like that's a big mistake and that's
what joe biden did i mean this is just
joe biden has fallen and he cannot get
up so here is uh so joe biden began
we'll start with with what he said
politically and then we'll get to just
the fact that the man is not with us he
is no longer with us
so he began by trying to defend all of
his vaccine mandates and now here's the
thing with people who've already been
vaccinated they're fine with vaccine
mandates because it doesn't apply to
them it's sort of like when you pull the
american public on taxing the very
wealthy most americans are not very
wealthy so they're like okay it applies
to that guy not me so i'm okay with it
but that is not the question the
question is whether it is high priority
for most americans to force their
neighbors to get vaccinated and whether
people who are anti the vax mandates are
very passionate okay and they are the
answer is they are and when they become
an intransigent minority which is what
we have been seeing in places like
southwest airlines or ge they can shut
down the entire economy they can shut
down major businesses saying we are not
going to do something that you are
trying to force us to do
so joe biden's tack here is to say that
if he forces you to get a vaccine
against your will or to vaccinate your
child against your will which is what
they're trying to do with kids 12 to 19
and i guarantee you within three weeks
they're gonna be trying to do this with
kids five to eleven
when joe biden says this when his take
on this is stop whining about your
freedom
this old authoritarian that ain't gonna
go over great
the two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my covet
i mean come on freedom
come on freedom come on okay so i love
the line i have the freedom to kill you
with my covet and nobody wants to kill
anybody else with covet
okay that's why we have the vaccine if
you don't want to die of covet i have a
good solution for you get a vaccine okay
and if you are immunocompromised even if
you take the vaccine that's not going to
be enough you need to protect yourself
with kn95 you need to be in a more
isolated area period
beyond which even if you're vaccinated
you can now pass the disease we know
this for a fact a huge number of people
who are being infected with kovid
already have been vaccinated so this
baseline so basically what he's now
arguing is that you have no right to
breathe free air
that's what he's arguing because if the
idea is that your mere breath creates
externalities whether you're vaccinated
or non-vaccinated we are talking now
about masking up until the end of time
that is a freedom issue
that's a freedom especially when again
everyone around you has the freedom to
protect themselves as i've said before
what joe biden is basically arguing is
no longer that you must wear a seat belt
what he is arguing is that if somebody
else doesn't wear a seat belt you have
to put a mattress on the front of your
car to catch them when they go flying
through their windshield
and that is a very different argument
and not only is it the different
arguments a bad argument coming from the
president of the united
st how did anybody think that this guy's
a good politician is absolutely beyond
me
he is he is thick
he is thick as an unripe coconut it's
it's just it's incredible
okay so moving on from his vaccine
policies which are deeply unlikely to
actually bring an end to the pandemic he
then is asked about rising gas prices
because as it turns out inflation is
crippling a lot of american families
right now the gas prices are out of
control and prices at the shelves are
out of control we're seeing major supply
shortages here is joe biden's wonderful
answer on the gas prices
so there's there there but i i don't i
must tell you i don't have a near-term
answer
there's two things i could do i could go
on the petroleum reserve
and take out and probably reduce re
reduce the price of
gas maybe
18 cents or so a gallon it's still gonna
be above three bucks and one of the
things that i refuse to have happen
because i didn't want anybody i made a
commitment if you pass the stuff i'm
talking about
not not one single penny in tax would go
against anybody making less than 400
grand and so if you notice this is these
highway bills are not paid for by gas
tax they're paid for by direct
expenditures in other areas so the
average person doesn't have to pay more
so really he's lowering your gas price
by spending a lot of money get it
no because he's incoherently babbling
like a crazy person
yeah that is the that is the president
of the united states right there well
done everybody
then joe biden is asked about the labor
shortages because we have tremendous
labor shortages in this country we have
10 million open jobs we have millions of
people who aren't going to fill them and
his answer is less than satisfying shall
we say
people are now using this as an
opportunity to say wait a minute do i
want to go back to that 7 hour job i
won't name the particular
restaurant chain but they found out when
they couldn't hire anybody when they
found out they started to pay 20 bucks
an hour
everybody want to go back to work not a
joke so he's admitting the quiet part
out loud guys he's making my case
he's now admitting that people are
faking about being afraid of kovid
in order to raise their own wages
right that they are relying on
government benefits to try to pry higher
wages out of businesses that are then
going to pass on that cost to consumers
because when you artificially raise the
cost of labor just like if you
artificially raise the cost of any other
input in a product you artificially
raise the price of the product at the
end of the of the supply chain
he said he's admitting it and he's happy
about it right he's happy that he's
artificially increasing the wages of
labor which is resulting in the
inflation that we are seeing right now
he is creating the labor shortages and
he's excited about it he thinks it's a
good thing that isn't a bug that's a
feature of his plan so if you're worried
about inflation he's promising you more
of it if you're concerned about supply
shortages he's saying it's good that
there are supply shortages because
finally the seven dollar an hour workers
will be getting 25 bucks an hour for the
same work now i have a question for you
do you think that their labor suddenly
became worth 25 an hour or do you think
that price is just gonna get passed on
to you the consumer and to those same
workers by the way because right now
inflation is outpacing wage growth
so his entire plan is a fail but it's
always more cowbell always and forever
more cowbell
and then as we'll see in just a second
joe biden decided that he would talk a
little bit about his economic plans
he suggested for example that um he
would be sleeping alone if he could not
get free community college done which uh
yeah we know jill is really running the
administration joe we get it
so the question was on the the on
community colleges
which was a big campaign
promise that that you made you talked
about that along the campaign trail yeah
and i'm going to get it done
and if i don't i'll be sleeping alone
for a long time
but here's the deal
oh it's the honeymooners now we all have
to pay for community college so that um
he can get some from his wife apparently
that's the uh that's that's great
yep
terrific joe
also joe says that um
this is it i wish you were telling the
truth here he says that we have a
commitment to defend taiwan if china
should militarily attack taiwan this is
immediately walked back by the white
house
i don't want a cold war with china i
just want to make china understand that
we are not going to step back we are not
going to change any of our views so are
you saying that that the united states
would come to taiwan's defense if china
attacked yes we have a commitment to do
that
okay so uh then the white house walked
that back like oh well we haven't
changed any status quo no no we don't
offend the chinese so even when joe
biden said something right he says
something wrong
okay and all of this is ancillary to the
major question here which is whether joe
biden's even competent to hold his
office
and the answer of course is that he's
not he is now in
late stage weirdness
right as if you've ever had an elderly
relative who's starting to lose it there
are certain ticks that you see that are
just strange
and joe biden is not
he's non-compost memphis he is he is not
with us
so during the middle of this town hall
joe biden was was talking about the long
beach port and he started asking what he
was doing
i was able to go to the private portion
with 40 of all products coming into the
united states of america on the west
coast go through
uh los angeles and uh and um uh
um
what am i doing here is it long beach
long beach thank you
oh my god
what am i doing here
what am i doing here so remember that
time that rick perry ran for president
and he wanted to name three departments
that he wanted to cut and he only came
up with two and it ended his
presidential campaign here you have the
president of the united states not
remembering the long beach port and
instead of finding something to cover
for just saying and another port in the
area instead he goes
what am i doing here and anderson cooper
jumps in to save him as our media
members typically do then we have this
weird image of joe biden clenching his
hand for no reason as though he has like
a a vest strapped to him and the button
in his fists i don't know like what is
he even doing here here's anderson
cooper ask him a question and the visual
is the president of the united states
holding his arms at 90 degrees
and um and clenching his fist with his
thumbs up as though he is going to clock
in on jeopardy for for the hot round of
questions
about that with just in terms of
inflation because you had told uh us at
a town hall i think it was in july
that the in this was just near-term
inflation
the wall street journal recently talks
is like 67 uh financial experts who said
that they they saw high inflation going
all the way or deep into 2022. what is
he what is he doing what is he doing
he's just he's kind of staring off into
the distance and clenching his fists
so one of two things is happening either
the president of the united states is
losing it or
he is corn jolio in search for tp for
his bungle those would be the only two
possible options here i i do not know
what the president of the united states
is doing here remember every time trump
did something weird people would like
jump on it and it was it was evidence
that he was crazy and that they needed
to use the constitution to get rid of
him and
what is he doing what does he do and
then he did the weird creepy whispering
routine i don't know who once told joe
biden that it is a good political tactic
to creepily
lean forward and whisper
but that's what horror movie villains do
right that that's where they've got the
victim tied to a chair and they lean
forward and they're like tell me about
your mother
so now you have the president of the
united states doing this here we go
now here's the deal though
you have 55 corporations for example in
the united states america making over 40
billion dollars don't pay a cent
not a single little red cent
now i don't care i i'm a capitalist i
hope you can be a millionaire or a
billionaire i not a pro but at least pay
your fair share
don't pay a cent
what's going on with this guy why do you
okay so here's the problem for democrats
the only person who has the leverage to
actually force through joe biden's
crappy plans joe biden is trapped okay
his plans suck and if they are
effectuated then it's going to be bad
for the economy he himself is admitting
he is going to create labor shortages if
his plans actually work it is not going
to create more jobs it's going to create
fewer jobs he's gonna be paying people
to stay home he's going to be paying
people not to enter the workforce but
instead to go to community college to
major in lesbian dance theory
this is the president of the united
states actual plan so if he succeeds he
fails and if he fails he also fails and
right now he has no leverage inside his
own party
democratic voters are getting very upset
with joe biden because they feel like
he's not able to use his leverage but he
doesn't have leverage guys
you elected a guy with no leverage
again the only thing that joe biden had
leveraged for was the things like the
bipartisan infrastructure plan
but he has a narrow majority and the
progressives are holding up the deal on
that so he has no leverage he has 50
seats in the senate which means he has
no power and in the house he has a very
narrow majority and a fractious
coalition it turns out the governing is
real tough
and joe biden again he doesn't have the
capacity to actually broker deals
because he is not there he's not there
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]